Die weltraumstation jahrgang 1 ist inzwischen auf einer höhe von unter 170 kilometern über der erdoberfläche
abgesunken und befindet sich damit
bereits in der äußeren erdatmosphäre die dort geben allerdings noch relativ dünn sie wird also bereits langsam
abgebremst die raumstation bewegt sich seit märz
2016 unkontrolliert auf die erde zu
Jetzt ist ziemlich genau bekannt wann sie abstürzen wird also alles zum absturz von rang eins wann und wo
Schlagen die trümmer auf der erde ein jetzt den klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Das ist eine ziemlich große raumstation nicht vergleichbar media es ist aber doch schon ganz schön schwer mit 8,5 tonnen hier nochmal die
wichtigsten infos übersetzt heißt die erste chinesische nicht dauerhaft bemannte raumstation
So viel wie himmlischer palast sie ist etwa so groß wie ein linienbus und
ausgestattet mit einem 14 kubikmeter
Großen labor sowie einer kleinen wohn ecke für die besucher von herrn koch 1 in den letzten sechs jahren hat das raumlabor
mehrere kopplungsmanöver mit
chinesischen raumschiffen der zensur, reihe hinter sich gebracht
Im september 2011 hatte china chang dong 1 ins all geschickt und jetzt nach sieben jahren stürzt sich station mit ihren
8,5 tonnen gewicht auf die erde eigentlich sollte sie kontrolliert zum absturz gebracht werden aber dann
Brach der funkkontakt ab die station ist nicht mehr steuerbar und stürzt jetzt eben
unkontrolliert auf die erde schon, im letzten jahr war tagung 1 wohl außer kontrolle geraten china kann das labor schon seit märz
2016 nicht mehr steuern die folge rang eins bewegt sich seitdem
unkontrolliert auf die erde zu im oktober kreis sie die station nach chinesischen berechnungen wohl noch in einer mittleren
Höhe von etwa 3 111 kilometern, im mai. Davor waren es noch rund 350 kilometer und jetzt sind es nur noch exakt
167 kilometer wobei
Die höhe zuletzt mit zehn kilometern pro tag gefallen ist also auch jetzt schon wieder etwas niedriger sein dürfte das beschleunigt sich in den nächsten
stunden dramatisch
Bis sie abstürzt regelmäßig gibt es dazu status updates aus china ab einer
höhe von 200 kilometern wurde die station deutlich schneller durch den luftwiderstand
abgebremst jetzt gibt es aktuelle berechnungen wonach teil der chinesischen raumstation
schon in den nächsten stunden
Auf die erde stürzen werden es ist jetzt ziemlich genau klar die chinesen schätzen einen eintritt in den frühen morgenstunden des
Zweiten april das ist bei uns ab 18 uhr am ersten april eine riesige frage aber ist wo werden die trümmer
Abstürzen es ist nicht das erste mal dass wir uns mit
Weltraumschrott gedanken machen müssen weil er auf kollisionskurs mit der erde ist wieder in der eine oder andere von euch
1991 viele bruchstücke des sowjetischen raumstation
207 auf argentinien arab menschen wurden zum glück nicht verletzt
weltraum experten und expertinnen fordern ja immer wieder dass ausgediente stationen und satelliten direkt
Im weltraum recycelt werden anstatt zieht weiter mehr oder minder
unkontrolliert auf die erde stürzen zu lassen fest steht für tiangong 1 die station ist nicht mehr steuerbar und
Stürzt jetzt ab dabei wird ein großteil verglühen aber 30 prozent
Wahrscheinlich nicht alles was aus edelstahl oder titan gefertigt ist wird unweigerlich auf der erde landen und größere brocken
generatoren motoren und so weiter wahrscheinlich auch zwei bis drei tonnen dürften das
Im fall von tiangong 1 seien fest steht dabei nur dass dabei ein feuerball aus den
auseinanderbrechenden teilen entstehen wird wo das genau sein wird ist immer noch unklar und sieben stunden vor dem eintritt in die dichte erdatmosphäre
können in einem ersten schritt wahrscheinlich kontinente und städte ausgeschlossen werden aber
Weiterhin heißt es von expertinnen und experten
Das risiko von einem trümmerteil getroffen zu werden ist extrem gering zitat die
Wahrscheinlichkeit von einem trümmerteil verletzt zu werden ist so hoch wie die möglichkeit zwei mal in einem jahr von einem blitz getroffen zu werden
So holger krag von der esa also
nahezu unmöglich bislang wurde noch kein mensch von einem trümmerteil getroffen die station
Umrundet die erde in nur 90 minuten sie legt also in der minute mehr als 400 kilometer
bezogen auf die erdoberfläche zurück das heißt dass nur wenige minuten darüber entscheiden
Wo sie genau
Herabstürzt nur eins ist sicher hier in deutschland sind wir auf keinen fall betroffen auf mallorca könnte sie stürzen denn sie pendelt über der erde
zwischen dem 43 grad südlich und dem 43 grad nördlich und überall zwischen diesen beiden
breitengraden kann die raumstation abstürzen für die weltraumagenturen weltweit ist der absturz auf jeden fall ein glücksfall sie können ihre tracking systeme ausführlich testen
und so in zukunft
absturzopfer von trümmerteilen genauer bestimmen immerhin fliegen achtung
7500 tonnen weltraumschrott
Um die erde sobald sich etwas genaues weiß welches euch auf whatsapp schicken da erreichen euch die nachrichten ja sofort und gar
Wenn ihr also nichts verpassen wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir auch vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
garantiert und zur begrüßung gibt es ein kleines goodie von mir einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das aber mit der
Genau glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken, weltraumschrott das ende der raumfahrt droht klicks um
science-fiction immer wieder spannend finde ich mal sagen ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran